finals week finals today you know vinyls
today yesterday was the LCQ today is the
finals and we got a very good oh this is
definitely a bank when you have JDC art
going up against none other that range
you what a match we are about to have I
can't wait to actually see how this goes
down
yeah you know I feel like I haven't seen
these two guys play in quite some time
but it feels like they play in every
tournament as well it's like I have no
idea I wanted like a member I wanted to
say that but I was not sure but I'm not
sure how many times they've acts played
but that has been the year that we've
been living in Tekken 7 like it's been a
blur but it's been an amazing blur yeah
it's a blur with fireworks everywhere
around it got fired you know with
quesadillas everywhere because I love
quesadillas so you know all right so we
got JDC our versus ranch you here and
I'm you know we haven't really seen rent
you jump out of a Julia so I think we're
gonna see Julia again I would love to
see what his choice is going to be but
like we said we he has multiple
characters right so I mean I feel like
it might be a match I think he looks to
be locking in on Julia JDC our corn with
the dragon off it seems as he sets that
monitor back up yeah you know we have it
I had dinner earlier this week with JD
Co and he was talking about his
character choices and he just said like
to where he said three words he said are
murky stupid palaces now and that was
that was a you know him talking about
himself yeah yeah I said like I should
have never played our became look I know
that I'm alone in this but I loved his
armor King it didn't get him what he
wanted but I loved the way he played
armor King just the character didn't it
couldn't do it for yeah that's why he's
going back to dragon off an obviously
dragon off at the season 3 is so social
oh yeah oh yeah and he's been good
throughout the entire like taking seven
like lifespan at this point and I feel
like the the tweaks that they made have
definitely kept him like up there but
like a player like JDC are truly takes
advantage of it but here we go
JDC are rank qu next match that's a big
match of both these players because they
both have one and zero
so win here would put them you know a
2-0 a pretty solid spot to beads like
you know you're not guaranteed but it
gives you a nice little cushion to work
with down to counter it on top of it all
the shredder takes big gambles we were
talking about with a julienne you're
gonna need to do that if you want to get
that damage drops a wall combos oh yeah
such a big bump in bleed season 3 will
you get the wall bounce even on the side
and that wall fatty 1-3 such a strong to
us cool put the one one more down in
here but I get the wall oh no I thought
we're gonna see the 4.21 possibly get
another wall little chip damage on top
of it don't-don't-don't there Doug let
me show you how to duck real quick for
all purposes get off good ball break
never branch you hands off to try beware
you think I'm like a creek grandma I'll
give her that or something I feel like
that's the only way of worse mr. wall
you got a hand that down from
generations to generations bro can't
just go to a thrift store and buy
something like that oh my god breaking
every wall
we're really close to getting another
wall - nice crowd go kick their JD sir
up to zero real fast
oh don't punish them right you try
tapping him on the leg steel I like that
they're going to these low fo'c'sle I
feel like as dangerous versus rang true
he's been using that party crasher a lot
he's been using a lot of those shredder
kids as well
yep there's that party pressure like you
say before it's been so effective in
stopping everybody else's nutrigain not
so much versus JDC our could be the
character could be JD's - y'all know
round brown you see it right there look
yeah baby no round brown Parramatta if
JD CR takes their first game three
rounds straight on top of them yeah
right you not even thinking about
characters to change go straight to
stage select the finals last year yeah
with a bear with a bare and now he's
playing your character that where's bear
ornaments on her head it's kind of
contradicting right she's all about
nature and he's like yeah I'm gonna have
this bear in a tournament fight come on
range you make up your mind I'm just
kidding I'm just kidding
start the stream yeah this is a I want
to see what rank she was gonna do here
um he's obviously locked in with Julia
at this point so he's going to have to
make this count
seal up one all right now in this group
later Oh County everybody to Russian
assault front get the wall we'll do it
right now he's just stopping he is
controlling the neutral game this is
what we saw get ranked you then victory
versus the Saint girl get on and it's
not working he's like you can do it to
my homie
you ain't gonna do it to meet oh yeah
this like almost like no don't -
wrenching arrest every time he's writing
that mid-range
JD shots already in his face either with
the running to a down - or even a low
carry why not get out of my face what he
said
is wall carry good and ready with the
conversion not a lot of damage but that
positioning is important put a load this
time around Wow we almost ate that
running - nice cobbles there nice
diversion so that was big damage get off
of me I don't need any axes finally on
the board if this set okay wait a minute
ranked you waking up oh you messed up
the the shotgun you got down for what
it's dead a classic Julie a mistake
it's really weird bumper especially in
Technic cuz you're doing like down 4/4
into one it's really good Oh swung in
the middle realignment here Ken oh ok ok
Lawler wall combos I'll see you oh good
that was so good ranked you up around
right now he needs this to stay alive
yeah perfect range for that Warhammer
you know that's it's a low high mid but
if they leave the low hits it's not to
hide from your minis guarantees very
very strong low just write out a range
right there good oh this wall
threatening once again rank you is up in
this match though he's up around you see
now patient it feels like inputs find
ways to get in he's actually kind of
meeting JD star case face I know we
won't play the mid range let me get into
your gray stuff we'll see what happens
JD see how his defense still looking
pretty good but it's back to this wall
Oh greater kicks once again those big
gamble paying off
I like that not even gonna hit the wall
that's gonna be game number two for
ranked you Wow very full set here right
you looked pretty
I don't like he was in trouble in that
first game and even in the beginning of
this set but made that real quick
comeback
JDC are taking a breather
every time JDC I think it's always get
the chin scratch and the looking gives
you some something somewhere I don't
know where he would how was this Chan so
consistently itchy is that the is that
the tail right there is that the tail
he's like oh man I lost it you chin I
need time to think
activate the itchy chin yo that JDC your
chance I'll kind of dope outside just
the letter that was good yo guys you
like rain to to take the set make some
noise what about JT see your if you like
them to win make some noise
JT fee are always a fan favorite that's
the guy you take home to meet mom it's
quiet that talked that much just plays
ticking that's it alright we go game
number three are usually brothers like
jacking off players yeah sometimes
Mishima dojo here we go yeah even JT
start he was thinking about what stage
to choose and he just went right back to
the Mishima dojo which is the stage that
right you chose so he's going to find
out I guess he was comfortable in this
stage even though he lost
Ronna what what adjustments he makes
here if any went down to all the jab
this time this and it got him out of one
of those it floated him out of one of
those attacks he's been using so much
for this that was pressure stop look at
the lead already 45 seconds into this
first round game number three eat on a
side of JD CR where it comes rank too
big damage again back in the game get up
three this entire finals weekend that
was it must be something I only see in
on commentary because I feel like
everyone's homie oh yeah this weekend
it's been hooking everybody up I would
love to know the stats on that how many
kid okay get up three specifically have
work oh that was so good
that's what got the victory get
secretive but not this time it gets
burnt you oh we could have got no launch
there okay okay up to set one one fight
it's a big game here for both players
too because winning the set means that
you'll be up 2-0 in your home which is a
pretty nice cushion the Hat especially
gets everyone else because there's no
other person with the unbeaten record
yet okay boy a narrow rank your patient
nice those Russian Knights or whatever
what's the call it's called the knife
just tonight bro all right the car likes
switchblade or something in the movies
Russian or assault or something like
that India Russian knife assault yeah oh
boy she was airborne though so like it
wasn't gonna be a County hit Oh ain't
you swinging in the middle is getting
them in trouble yeah that's the second
time that's happened it was no wall
behind look at the offense he's starting
to use those those party crashes once
again three not your work and that's the
same movie close out that last round
with final final round here
ranked reverses JD CR it's getting tense
[Music]
finally the block and the punish jdc art
here to win he smelled it once again
you're trying to get rain through the
swing not giving it to him though JCCC
are one hit away and that's gonna do it
JD CR to won against ranked you right
now and that's good - all right now in
that group C play that's gonna put rank
to it one and one yes so now we have two
players or three players actually that
are tied up at one one apiece and the
person that's on top JD SAR the person
that's at the bottom unfortunately is
Saints two homies right there who
eventually ette to play as of yet I mean
these guys are like best friends for
like five years I'm pretty sure they had
a sitcom on a Korean TV channel
somewhere as best friends but let's take
a look at the bracket I've seen I'm
telling I've seen a poster or something
- Oh leading the group C play that's
gonna be JDC are ranked who you just saw
him go down one game that's gonna put
them at one in one Chickering pull out
right behind them all at one and one in
st.
sitting there down with the zero
and two he needs to make some changes if
he wants to stay alive have a chance of
making it out but it's not looking too
good right now yeah but you know he's
definitely not out of it yet he just has
to you know he has to win and he has to
win big he has to win these next two
sets that he's gonna play and yep he
wants to do it with two O's he doesn't
want to give him any games here all
right I believe he will actually be
sitting up on stage next going up
against oh wow
so tricky when we just saw him playing
super strong as well I mean it's gonna
be really hard to slow him down we've
seen what he's done with geese so far
but I want to hear some words let's uh
let's get a video from saying don't know
what that I'm going the propeller and
you saw what I saw once or two new
encouraging us to go green and
torrential America kilo tokahana a
pterosaur donkey named we could go to a
place 38.3 Paquita with it
cool so we were talking about him
changing up his hairstyle and the
gameplay what he was just talking about
was like self-care right these are very
high tense situations that we come and
play and you know this firsthand so I
encourage everybody out there take some
advice from sync take care of yourself I
mean it's really really hard to do he's
a high stressful situations but he
focused on self growth this will still
able to make it to the finals here in
his group play and he has to make
something happen right now so shut us
the Saint man and shut us to Gigi for
picking up my boy saint man I'm really
happy he found a home a good home at
that but uh he still got his work cut
out for him cuz Chickering don't care
about none of that
yes sir you know earlier this year I
believe that evil
and I think these two guys played in the
top eight and chicken actually the lone
Japanese player in that top eight was
able to beat out Saint inside okay okay
I will see you how it goes here geese
versus Jack I don't think we'll see any
character swaps I mean we did see you
say actually switched to Bob earlier
today so if things get hairy you know we
might see the Bob come out wrong alright
there we go
geese versus Jack seven chick around
versus Saint here we go while standing
one just to start off great Pope's
coming from st. yeah right at the
beginning side step but there's a lull
Perry from [ __ ] and he's trying to
get this started early and he can break
this balcony of he wants to do with it
okay side step fort one down here well
yeah you could see Saints back right at
that wall already yeah so look that's a
big kind of food he's a until she loved
this entire set even move and we talked
about like how good how hide the
competition in how high the ceiling is a
king of Iron Fist tournament champion
right here in st. and if you know he's
having a hard time that let you know
just how good the talent is here
I say though with the okiya Jackson
finally pushing chickens back to the
wall man he got hit by that fireball
while he was sidestepping I'm like man
those childbearing hips bro he tried to
jump over the fireball too but he can't
get off the ground that hot it's too
heavy bro yeah he weighs as much as a
minivan
Oh sidestep oh wow he's gonna get the
wall of he places right yeah the four
one plus two jabs yeah he's dead so
unless he drops this he's definitely not
dropped yeah you see the rest of the red
bar go away man the damage before to me
to start it off nice no break that
particular tooth a little bit of big
damage when you try to go for that
volcano buster throw not gonna work out
count it down for one boy down for two
hits once again Saints back to the wall
what's wrong what is difference it night
in a minute small jack has like a good
jab as well but it just seems like
chicken is so good at pushing into this
wall I'm making him respect it that's
gonna hit through stretch this out a
little bit for st. this is just good
enough to get him off of the wall
obviously he dads don't worry Jenny more
so this cutbacks gonna be all real all
natural comeback don't know rage
steroids here no uh fighting msg is that
our cellar and go no HGH I don't think
robots would we have HGH but whatever
you see those things a robot
that was it yes all right there we go
st. finally on the board Jake we didn't
sitting on two meters something back
he's been very good with yeah just
sitting on that meter too like the last
round and sometimes not even meeting
right Wow look at that
let's try it Jupiter has been trying to
suite in this entire time what did I say
in the last round those jabs coming from
Jack seven oh really really good Saint
knows we'll all too well about how to
lose can't believe he's suede out of the
way right there that was crazy
oh nice try the same once again going
back to those jabs take him back to the
wall there's the activation he's got
plenty a meter to close us out team
number one is gonna go to Chickering man
Saints not doing well right now yeah he
went for a hill married now for it's you
she could've had the partners on lock he
had three meters it was just one of the
you know just a bad choice there from
saying don't see Mike say he's gonna
switch characters and you heard what
Saint said he said he'd felt like
staying loyal to one character was
something that he had to let go it was
more about you know understanding and
adapting his playstyle to be able to
deal with these situations especially
when there's so many threats out there
especially in the Tekken World Tour in
2019 so you can see just how hard of a
draw that is st. getting a lot of
encouragement from the crowd out there I
hear you guys it is your dose oh yeah
dose the sequel you thought the world
was good before wait till we take you
back
see Saint playing back a little bit once
again you like these infinite stages -
you like to control the space saw those
jabs in that last game start to work out
for them wasn't able to close out but
you see the thought process you see it
starting to open up speaking of opening
up while rising one big combo from st.
here takes the O key great sound walk
tricycle for the hook he was just a
little bit early on that it definitely
would work yeah but you know it's so
hard for Jack because he's the
childbearing hips
yeah man you have to think even one move
further ahead if you really want to stop
it it's definitely tough what you I
guess I deserve before you have to take
the risk just backing up here same
complaint patient Wow just wrong cold
not that kind of robot boy Oh flex on
them note back to at the end yeah season
three change I used to be a high now
it's mid I keep getting hit by it all
the downpour is so good lunch three
seconds left on the clock
and here comes Saint yeah chica who got
scared he wanted to kill up you will
kill st. immediately but all the county
here on the wall 72 109 job you're
insane damage all first down that is
pretty good that's really good
okay small damage right there Wow before
it got to the armored parties while
standing for Saint with a nice lead here
but you could have does have rage and
two meters very scary you've been seeing
him ask out like those fireballs with
power crush and even rage art sometimes
so I'm really interested see what's
about to happen chick around with rage
zone just about 20 seconds left on the
clock annie has two bars on top of it
there's the activation who tries to go
for the interrupt and this is gonna cost
still ran
man way he is not dropping that bad boy
nice job chicken it pretty risky there
from sitting all Bannon sits down for
tubes you know they offer him all that
much in this set it's been a little back
and forth right check my playing out of
that range where you're not gonna be
able to typically you know you down for
two and he's not swinging enough to get
the hit speaking of swinging night
sidewalk and that should be the round
once again Chickering on set point st.
is in a lot of trouble right now
yes this could be this could be his
final last hurrah here at the tech world
tour finals in 2019 unless he doesn't be
big here nice got down for you to go so
well this entire day actually a
sidestepping those key moves you know
the jackhammers here they say they're
running to is from dragon off and then
getting back some damage out of it do
something here got the nice little lead
here but it does have one meter and gray
just dangerous Oh like I think I steps
and that should be easy stuff that
taiko drums and that's gonna play st. at
oh and three in this group C play that
is nothing to sneeze at but that's gonna
be man that's a really hard draw right
now is making it look like it's not
gonna be able to make it out he's gonna
is gonna have to be some crazy upsets if
Saints gonna make it out I'm pretty sure
it's mathematically impossible I'm not a
mathematician I'm no mathematician I can
barely count to four I'm like a lucky
Chloe player but unfortunately zero and
three he's at the bottom I believe he is
eliminated from this tournament JDC are
you see at the top alongside chickweed
in both 2 0 and 2 1 respectively grant
you and bilal tied up at 1 1 apiece and
those guys are gonna have to play soon
and we're gonna have to see some pretty
big upsets here too
yeah it's gonna have to be some crazy
swings and momentum of us Saints gonna
have a chance but even still we've seen
what happened with rang true ranked you
going down to JDC R and that last set
JDC are looking super strong so far
while still there as well I mean you
still got people alive in this in this
group see it's still open for anyone and
we got a match coming up next up allow
versus grant you this is one of the
matches I've been waiting to see in all
honesty I heard him that he made it out
hour so I was gonna go to group C pull
out versus the Tekken World Tour 2018
champion ranked Chu this is gonna be
crazy in the draft stage right where it
was the top it was the top three and the
LCQ bailout gonna get a chance to choose
his pool his pool was pretty much
predetermined but his pool was before
every player avoided right he avoided
this pool and it can avoid this low high
avoided this pool and Bulow had had to
go into this one with this two former
champions of watch Evo champions
well I mean if you look at it he's still
doing pretty well yeah you still did it
everyone still in it I want to see what
range who's gonna go with that Julie has
been giving a giving him a lot a lot of
payout so far so don't be surprised I
mean it didn't work out too well versus
Jay DCR but still I mean he's been doing
great that was a close up they're all
wait a minute
yo guys we might have the pan that the
champ might be back in the building
yeah everyone's happy about this oh the
Akuma is he hovering the he's hovering
near coober oh man he's gonna do it the
Akuma finally comes back out we've been
seeing a fall out there Brian a lot but
the Akuma the to stop all the others is
the Akuma from below
alright guys and this is a little bit
risky right Akuma and and the bear is
really nice really really not is really
not all right guys it's quiz time if you
guys would like bülow to take it make
some noise out there
what about though the 2018 Tekken World
Tour champion ranked you make some noise
for ranked you if you want to take he's
got some love out there sir I mean
there's a lot of bear fans out there I
know a few that swore off of rent you
every time he does a play panda and
already you can see that down 4-2 to
start off with that bear twin piston Wow
don't punish there from my blog you see
how that that uh that bear stands
actually ducked under the fireball look
like yeah got a few options here but
this is what one of the hard things
about this matchup more of air player is
that a lot of these strange into
fireball normally for a lot of
characters you can step to punish but
not the Bears they're a little bit too
fast
like that more for to block for three is
that a party yes that one on the parties
on the cheek left-handed that's it be
game number one Allah the be cliff can I
don't even know
Roman Antonia Waldo he's getting closer
and closer look out rain to his side
stepping right to make sure he stays so
much closer to keys keep up allow in
that corner he's moving them over
they're trying to put them in timeout
no you know how there's goals out to
drop yeah a little bit harder especially
cos bear has some small lakes that could
be a little bit tougher even though it's
easier this uh in this season Perry Wow
Wow
we're drop there got the hut double hop
kick thank you with a slight light weed
here 20 seconds left though Oh rule that
down - he's trying is fishing for look
at the in and out for rain shoe though
yeah that down to all the counter hit on
the forward for that's a few buff here
in season three he's gonna carry through
this wall that's gonna be it make damage
two rounds right there football out
looking very strong it's gonna be tough
around you to make this comeback
nice I like that out of hunting stance
just making sure but I wasn't getting
any offense started cancels in this time
around as a focus once again in Malawi
has no problem fighting with his back to
the wall
even though range who seems like he's
kind of guiding him there he does not
have a problem with it cuz I hello I
feel like has faith that you can get off
of that wall with one down two with one
standing to into a fireball he's not
gonna let that combo drop down three
down four oh we went for it again the
wild rides into for the punish this
could be trouble yes this could do a ton
of damage
oh wait for the wall stand keep turning
stands that's around on the side for
ranch ooh nice shot there for hu staying
alive here at this game number one if
you fighting hard one you guys have a
tied record all chop the combo though
that could've been a pig with punishing
look at this movement from Ranchi just
making him second-guess some of these
ranges he wants to play a buffalo in
trouble he still has the lead but he
just got floated out small of damage
terrible okay no meter so he's still
alive
that demon flip gets him a little bit on
the side down for two that's duck the
down 41 three yards you know
[Applause]
once the game reach running it back two
rounds I said once again for the first
time around yeah that wall was just in
the in the worst spot from Ranchi but
he's still able to click down o counter
hate not close enough to get the combo
to lose looked out right there whoa
they're gonna pull them out but nothing
nothing able to come from that flow
right there just drop those quick piss
they got County didn't even get me a ton
of damage here Wow all genatech track
don't go oh wow and that's one of the
things that Ranger does a lot like the
test with that down for 200 County I
don't go into the WoW yv2
drain - loves to do that he loves to
check you with it down for - to see if
you're ducking yeah and then later on he
lets it rip cuz you're like oh he's not
gonna do it man that was beautiful
beautiful comeback that Brent you down
two rounds making that comeback well
we've seen this from below every time
you know he seems like the first name he
always feels like I I got a you know not
it's not on point but then he just makes
that comeback mm-hmm what can he do it
again cuz he wasn't able to do it again
stick wooden he's gonna stick with the
Akuma it seems like not trying to go for
the brine which has kind of done him
wonders even drank all that water that
water the bottom just fell on the floor
worthless to him there's no water left
in his bottle toss it this bottle is of
no use to me you've served your purpose
for the low of this time around okay the
while standing poor not gonna work out
too well
combos gonna get the water comes full
out now Oh drop the copper they're a
little hard to hit on bears get you
talked about the fact and I like to
mention it like the bear hitbox is
really weird those legs are so far back
you gotta be careful back one that nice
that was a great bunny sniffle I'll note
even knowing that the second here the G
cup plant is also minus 14 Oh missed it
my boy Bilal just stand-in there
I love I dare you to move do it it's so
scary
we're trying to hit me and hit me over
while standing for and it's also one of
those six - I hate when people do that
and you think like oh they're not moving
there's a control okay yeah right part
of the minutes not only make me freak
out Oh works out this time no down four
on top of it this round looking
spectacular for pull out and this is
what we've seen from below he went down
the game to begin with and comes back to
round straight in the second game and
he's got fooled me yeah this is terrible
spots for ant you right now down to got
blocking the hole there we go nice low
very they're French you sniffed it out
Oh bear booty hold that power crush
trying to keep that wall steel back one
you're gonna convert okay
four three two get the tail spin stop
kick on top of it the forecourt to run
to get the wall okay below I get it
while riding - after the block down four
here comes Ranger yeah he could have
actually converted after that running
three but didn't think that meant you
would see on the floor steel meter all
the side oh wow it's not gonna matter
though it comes ranked you once again
now I can say one thing it yet another
comeback here would be paid for rent you
especially wait to zero against bull out
the jab out once again I think oh my
demon flip accident you switch sides as
well power crash now for one one for the
power crush get wasps which decides back
now you hear the electricity go off that
means he's got full meter and instantly
spent some of it I'll crash punished
again with a down for one one oh wait
for rain - and the Panda set point right
now for rain to four very close here wow
it does have one meter I'll hit him out
of the air almost had a float - so close
goes for it blog that want to punish Oh
out of the air brings you close an air
right now pull out need this round
branch ooh
to zero making two comebacks in both
games to take out the long we've been
saying this all day people kind of
forgot ranch ooh is there look at the
hair is it the new characters no it's
the place that my man ranked you still
alive in this group see play everybody
knows I'm a fan of rain truth duh I'm
happy to see him succeed the bubble out
he's still in there too it's getting
down to the nitty gritty
1 in 1 right now you can see it over
here in Group C play JDC are sitting
pretty with the 2 o Chickering to 1
range you also to 1 so we're working
with a tie right now and you can see the
rounds are actually perfectly time so
they are perfectly tied right now yes in
the group play for C and of course you
see Saint down there and only three of
allow round and out with the 1 & 2 after
the loss right there 2 ranked you yeah
it's gonna be tough for both allow ant
st. to make to crack the top 8 but they
still have well I'm pretty sure Saint is
out but I think Bo out has a small
chance very very small but he's gonna
need a lot of help from a lot of people
man this is uh this is kind of like a
super throwback right here I'm telling
you these guys used to have a sitcom I
used to hang out with him it was all
laughs and smiles this yeah this is
throwback to 2017 Grand Finals of every
tournament right every tear tournament
in 2017 with this this is the fun this
is the finals remember how everyone was
like residentsleeper Jack and Dragan off
now it's like Jack a dragon off say what
haven't seen a dragon elf oh man but a
Saints gonna need a lot right now I mean
semantically it seems like it's not
gonna be possible but who knows yeah but
you know Saint can't play spoiler here
you know he could actually put put a
little wrench into JDC arse plan of
making toffee and you know JC our last
year obviously he was so close to making
top eight and just wasn't able to crack
that you
beat up make it out fool yeah this is it
right now and he's in a good spot but
it's still not guaranteed yet man this
is so close yeah this is really really
close it's kind of been that way right
we talked about like who can be like
troublemaker right because we saw shadow
throw a wrench oh yeah earlier in his
group route the biggest I've ever seen
look man if you think this format
doesn't make a difference go back and
look at group a it definitely makes a
big difference right now so you better
play like you mean it
st. versus JD see our friends become
full on the ticket World Tour space bar
lion even try to do it but it worked
these guys obviously this is a set they
have so much history together playing in
every single Grand Finals of every
tournament known to man in 2017 it
didn't matter what game it was these two
guys were always in the finals but it
back thing they also felt like they
would always go back and forth as well
so and it feels like I haven't seen them
play in such a long time and I mean if
you think about it right like Saint like
I swear I feel like you went on like a
spiritual journey man he went he had the
changing hairstyles traveled everywhere
got a new sponsor he got his groove back
he's back in the swing of things right
and you see JDC are still rocking the
you know the hoodie rocking his a Tekken
jacket criminally unspotted I'm always
gonna say that but here we go leading in
this group seat play is gonna be JD CR
vs. G G same sir
and this is a throwback you better be
using the default outfit right now we
don't even need to play with some
special outfits listen those are for the
new kids right we don't need no stinkin
customization never bad it's 2017 we
even have costumes we had to play with
the same two colors right sometimes they
pick the same even know who I was
yeah it was like a black-and-white
television you couldn't tell which color
we were sometimes look at his cowboy
though from JD Sehun all the tackle get
off of me clicks off stay right there
almost got in trouble from that Russian
assault from JD see our Saint does have
range you know you know JD see our
notice is that too soon as st. has rage
he kind of pumps the brakes a little bit
now loud st. to be a little bit more
aggressive fund cuz you know st. is
pretty loose foot witness of HR usage I
could have carried to this wall nice
while horizon-1 yeah Scott step back
into it that was crazy
takes the okie instead I'm closing it
back to state trying to push gate it to
the wall now positioning himself right
in the middle of the stage of the
Octagon look at him just dancing in the
JDC arse face oh my god right Davis is
holding that boy realizing - wow look at
this stage he's playing brave right now
but but he has a look at what he's done
on both the blue one Wow st. looks very
strong here in this fight really trying
to throw a wrench in his friends plans
he's like we were boys once boys no more
okay
wall carry once again mange dzr and his
convergence for these wall combos have
been stellar all day dude they've been
like really really good when the Train
once again here comes Jay DC arc back
trying to get back in the swing of
things who's been playing really good in
this group play where he is fighting his
friend and he's looking like he's having
a hard time what a sad fellas yeah
beautiful side shot there that
jackhammer used to be the war this was
terrorizing moved for the day but now
it's a little bit easier to step still
such a good mood in him and Anakin were
kind of responsible to their right they
need to read they're like man is moving
it made everyone feel like they could
play Jack when they realize I get
checked not that easy it's not just you
know jackhammer and down back one you
know but when you say over your Anakin
you can make it look very easy there's
no doubt for one JDC our man I told you
he's been playing
combien turn eight the bar fight huh
what's the guest blocks the town - no
way actually like I did know like
something happened like hit him and it
was like a sliver of light and I was
like what is the trend that what's about
to happen
oh my gosh like I said who st. is loose
with the with the rage arts man he does
not care he'll let them go but his
reactions with them he what you when he
throws was out I feel like his hit
written his hip person is like 90% he
loves like I feel like he's one of those
players he takes advantage of the power
crush in the most like successful
reasons and I say that because he uses
rage arts the same we saw him do it when
he was playing chicken he threw over
pork and he tried to do 444 to eat it
just to get the hit so you know he's
paying attention to it JDC are looking
like he's in trouble right now he's
using all of his friendship memories
against them that's not nice man it's
not cool like I said there's no friends
in the pool
it's terrific a pool in pool play you
have no friends only enemies
yeah talk to me afterwards bad one fight
game to here
of course two out of three is the name
of the game nice duck therefore say
while rising one on top of it man he is
starting to open up his play using a lot
of different attacks just to you know
get thrown small pieces of damage
wait a minute while standing to JDC our
combos and wall carry with drag have
been stupid good today yeah stupid
obviously you know they gave gee they
keep jacking off such a nice little putt
one in the wall carry which almost
really didn't need but whatever no have
no player you'll take anything oh we
tried to go for backswing blow tap them
on the right sign the wall yeah
beautiful waters down front you drop the
cobble to sign those my characteristic
oh yeah now what's not guarantee you can
still break that throw what it's about
the attendant yeah oh oh my shoulder
that be damaged I finally caught him
slipping to down for for this time close
out JDC are two rounds this time what a
switch up gets the counter hit on the
one-to-one hey Rick you round as well
does evil out state to really have rage
whole county hit on the wall this time
big damage oh my god good the turnaround
has been a regular
jvc are not letting go
walks off into the sunset that's the
game three that might have been the
fastest game of the entire day
man that was super quick and you see
what st. dick goes instantly to The
Devil's pit knows exactly what he was
gonna do I like that I love the fact he
already had a plan for the situation
yeah the devil play obviously very
interesting stage because it is a walled
stage for the first two or three rounds
until you get to the set point in the
game where it becomes an infinite stage
it's not a stage that normally people
keep pick right think about it like this
though we've talked about the fact that
he likes me he likes he uses that
spacing to control right so by the time
it gets to the third round
having him having infinite space is good
for saying this is using the new rules
to his advantage we're one of the few
who's been using that stage select rule
to his advantage that same ijd cell with
a nice novel here though to punish there
while you've all had a shot using a lot
more upward force especially with all by
God you could have just go oh that
wasn't a ysg combo video right there in
the making my man's getting loose my man
JD CRM didn't loose yeah you tried to
use kyo she combos but he realized those
are the wrong four letters of his name
Aleph not me
whenever the walls too jagged ops right
side you see a lot more upward force
these rounds if not the board won't
proceed at all
nice block the down or and the perfect
seven golden letters med st. now one
round away from point O and four in this
group stage not something that we done I
expect him to do but he's on the
infinite stage now maybe this will help
him out like we say man his record
doesn't really a fit well for what
happened is what's happening in your new
play is looking pretty dead to rights
right now but still fighting like he
means it out respect no matter what you
have to fight even if it's your boy yeah
you gotta put it all in the game man
we'll be friends after this is done but
until then I hate you
yeah well you're the choir in the
background it's poetic friends fighting
or two catches them out of the air
traffic stabilized with a down 4-1 yeah
he tried to actually get a comma after
that that would have been so nice now
for one closes it out come baby this you
know maybe he should have gone to the
infinite stage right off the bat foot
maybe he wanted to switch up the pace in
the middle of the game you know
something different
I mean it's music is too good at doing
meteors in the background right speaking
so focused on this fight they don't care
about the volcano or anything
jackhammer works out Oh big whip
nobody's dead from dragging off we saw
made this combo earlier will it be the
kill no almost you know say you can't
use this radar now like you like anymore
oh my god
the down for one JDC are continues the
streak right now yes sir JDC are now is
three and no a solid solid record here
that's gonna be and that's it
I think that's gonna guarantee him a top
eight spot that's what I was looking
this is exactly what I was talking about
if you go and you look at these other
groups you can see how pivotal that
number is you do not want to have any
losses on the side because you don't
know what those other players are
capable so picking your group is super
important and you even said before the
bailout really didn't have a chance to
pick his pool and now you see how much
of a difference that makes right going
into a pool but you're not sure how
you're going to perform is really really
dangerous and look how it turns out well
yeah also remember the guy that's up top
JDC are when he chose his pool there was
no names on the board he was number one
he had to choose any random pool and he
just chose to full seat and he was
immediately targeted by G Curtis and
people came to him I love that the
people pick first like no you come to me
you want to fight come to me children
immediately chosen but then his pool was
avoided so hard and I ran Palau and st.
both weren't able to choose their pool
and they just were kind of put into that
position and man JT CR has shown why
people try to avoid this pool he's three
and
in this and we got another one between
branch ooh
and chicken but before we get into this
next match I would love to hear what my
boy rang chu has to say about the Tekken
world - it sounds him alone
we didn't arrow to vote every Sunday
they seem are they able to hear what L
had to go
we couldn't on his final money on about
them well Sam you know that means a lot
I mean if you think about the fact that
like what he's you know accomplished in
after you know becoming the Tekken World
Tour champion even before that just
playing consistently getting there now
sponsored by amplified steel here on the
stage what a great chance to make it to
the top eight yes sir and he's going up
against his good friend chicken and
these guys have been teammates in
various times you know they've teamed up
for various team tournaments they're
even training partners I believe the
rent you when he was in Japan for a
minute he would play with these guys
quite often she could in the Roma and
the guys from the west coast so
you sure I'm sure these two have played
each other a bunch well there we go
rang true versus chicken we've seen
chicken and play pretty we'll today um
that geese is gonna be a problem but
he's pulling the bear back out the back
on the scene yeah not you know not sure
why he's decided to choose which
character but I mean obviously he did so
well with Panda against bailout earlier
so this could be just maybe he's feeling
Panda today you know maybe or maybe he
just feels like there's more it's got to
be like last year I gotta win with my
character I mean I feel like if you if
you make the choice to say look I have
multiple characters like you gotta be
comfortable saying like you look I
probably can't play this character in
this matchup I might need so you know
switch up the tactic Brian here we go
ranked you sticking to his guns
look what got him here the pound he goes
back to the bandage nice block on the
floor one plus two for Tigger this is
not a match I don't wanna see all that
much so maybe there's there's definitely
gonna have to be some adjustment here
for lunch if you didn't to have to deal
with the bear well we talked about that
bear hitbox right those legs being a
little further back Jackie's gonna have
to commit a little harder if you want
something to happen and then her close
range is something you don't want to
deal with versus range head down for two
tests that he loves to do gets people in
a lot of trouble man and the hop kick
even kicks
I like that right one zero
see him try to learn something Wow your
love us too gets the full flow right
there
all right he's ready
he's come up with a good repair and
still get the bottom 34 sink if the
walls bladders will die which the sides
here pretty choice
get off for me that's my purse their
visa do they have
what are you having that purse right
there's just bamboo shoots right
a bamboo about almost ten seconds left
and ranked you in trouble but enrage
anything the trigger on that he
definitely had the hit Jupiter going for
it pretty risky move there it it's a mid
high rank you could've ducked that I'm
fine launch but he ended up getting hit
one round a piece game number one range
shoe and chicken that was definitely a
pair only thing right where he did the
Jake you know whatever the hell it's
called and this is the second hit just
straight up with a down for one get to
launch like you say a minute it brought
flow damage against I step three neutral
range with it and on top of that any
character that you fight you're going to
have to come closer to get those big
hits versus a character like manner you
know right you obviously has a great
reaction we saw it last year when with
blocking every health sweet note the man
oh all chicken to one in a round count
in his first game fight
i impotence stage as well right now
probably beneficial for rent you all
luckily all canceled yeah luckily for
enchi he was Air Force we took a little
damage there
in fact basically even it up that
grounded head it is a bad fighting a
bear okay I mean oh I know it's wearing
a you know a purse you know in a honzo
gonzo head but it's still okay okay damn
hug the dog go Panthers shop at the same
store huh I wouldn't be surprised
oh yeah uncle seems like eats bamboo
shoots right guys doubt that too for
grant you finish this one out
final round again number one here they
see a lot of sport one plus news from
chicken and trying to go over those lows
because that's kind of the main thing
for buff Hatton flares just down back to
you you gotta keep using that like that
you have to be willing to throw that out
look at the defense on the side of range
and definitely tighten it up a little
bit to one to one had these beater good
blocks just ran out of maximum so not
secret in in a pretty rough shape there
at the down back to closes it out this
time Frank you scratching the booty a
little bit I'm asleep I'm sleep that's
what that's what Pantages just say I
feel like they both she captured me for
that like that's how I feel like I sleep
I believe that you know you're tired
when you roll over it you roll over and
you don't care where it landed you want
everything off the like the night fans
like you didn't going to the geometric
plane this is definitely chicken in
stage I feel like he's the only player
on planet Earth that chooses the stage
on purpose
I feel like this fits his personality is
random squares floating in the
background all right here we go game
number two in the center chicken to one
just in case you guys aren't familiar
oopsy play ranked you 201 himself are
using a JCC are nice punished while
standing for when she couldn't win some
rounds if he hits up let's do it seems
like he gets that round blue stuff that
bear blue stuff still alive though still
alive though so close to low and the
punish nice tinker's yeah because
chicken was enraged actual Hill that
toddler would it have killed outside of
rage
nice sites up here he's gonna get a
little bit of damage will carry through
this wall please
we stand at this wall all right
Wow so much damage and just outside of
rage go punish oh wow I was ready for
that still alot though I can't believe
that jab hit nine patients there from
jig we did right you now down to zero he
definitely likes to make those look like
those Gamble's at the end he's pretty
good at scouting the down four to one
yeah but even still sometimes he just
swings thinking that the other person is
gonna get flustered and it didn't work
chicken back one two waiting it out and
it really feels like what what matters
is who gets the first crush who gets the
first would punish you'll you can see
ranks who fight his way back into this
game that should be the round and play
correctly ranked you not done yet
yo he took that first game he's down
around now but he's still fighting
squares everywhere there's like four
colors actually get a punish this time
usually chicken is pretty good on that
yeah actually cancel to hunting stands
right yeah that way you don't just get a
little bit further away see if you're
prepared to deal with it I get the wall
almost oh the jump yeah what do you do
jump once again I was just gonna say one
thing I like about chicken it in this
season it feels like this only for the
season he's been using jump in way more
you usually jump in especially Ricki ski
so jump is not as good as Akuma but
easily has the best jump geese probably
comes second with the lies in the third
but chickadee has been using that so
effectively throughout this entire
season I feel like yeah I definitely see
that as well I definitely see it as well
and on top of that like I feel like he's
a lot more reluctant to do it than most
leases right yeah like he does it a lie
he picks his spots he's like I'm gonna
do it now you probably weren't looking
for it I'm probably gonna hit you with
this and even if not at least you know I
got something else to deal with yeah I
mean it's definitely one of those things
where it's just it's a wild card like
you don't expect a player like she
couldn't just just the thought of jump
like that but he throws it out at such
specific timings where it's gonna crush
and it's good and he's gonna get maximum
damage out of it where you know if he'd
done the jumping a little bit too early
he doesn't get one an easy combo but
he's hitting it late so he gets a combo
after which is very very very very
difficult to do
nice little punished after chickadee
checking on the tolls well Mike that
honey stands gets the tailspin as well
and the wall mare serger barrage music
better yep it's a bad I got it I just
have to make sure for for to get delayed
I'll kick on top of it ranked you taking
his first-round game number three and
this is actually a big set here because
both these players are tied exactly not
only in match point in game points as
well so when did this say here could be
huge for their potential to actually
qualify and it both tied at two one this
is the court next this is super pivotal
to show up your chest
thank you two rounds to zero now she
couldn't has a huge comeback there's no
meter and in the third round they had
that be part my feed thousands first
time he has me yeah I feel like now with
a slower pace versus you know meter
characters definitely helped you out
right yeah
I chicken ain't going with I guess very
specific out wall combo sidestep three
to try to get something started ranked
choose back is to the wall we were
talking about those specific times where
he's using those jumps to anything will
do it right now
chicken in the lead almost half like
there's gonna be the punish on the twin
since Chickering still in this yeah
right you still willing to throw those
out he's not scared I mean he's worn to
bed at all once once walking like that
because one mistake Michiko didn't would
have wondered the round
I like that pushing closer to the wall
for one plus two once again
chicken use and ever just kind of boom
forth there's the activation off the
back three two spins the meter and he's
got one more left on top of it from wall
to wall
once wall walk down got nice damage
there
get off of me it's getting close getting
a little hairy both players is going
with the raw to final final round I
cannot believe this this is huge for
both players winner this puts himself in
great position to fall fight for the top
page aren't they tied on like everything
yeah it's it's difficult but it's all we
got
because this is both of them last
very important when it comes to the
standings another break Oh once again
this time under the for one plus two
chickens gotten a little bit of mileage
out of it this time he's in trouble on
the wall big damage life lead in favor
of rain - 30 seconds left on the clock
back three to spin to the poor and steal
gets a small combo right there that's
gonna be big particular he's just
outside a bridge to wall been counting
it though gotta be doing the power crush
I just spawned gonna put Ranger rage
Johnston bridge almost hit the wall
though old there it's chicken enrage
great throw and throw break for both
players changes the sides on top of it
that was so crucial then for a chew and
chew it in now we'll have he'll finish
with the three in one record which means
that he will I'm pretty sure I think
that means he's gonna find I think that
means he qualifies JD CR has the best
record out of this group play that is
possibly gonna put chicken at 3 1 ranked
you at 2 & 3 if I'm not mistaken
2 & 2 - in - yes so right now I believe
our last match will be JD so our vs.
balasso pulao actually will not be able
to qualify as well but I believe that if
go out does well enough in this game or
in this set he can actually push JD CR
to second and allow chicken into
actually qualifying winners ok alright
so there's a little bit of that players
I think we are guaranteed though
JDC Archie CUDA will qualify for our top
eight which is crazy to call my gosh
have you seen the back and forth in this
group see play look at the numbers
across all of them not only eight beat
but look at see as well look at how
close that's been the numbers mean
everything in this format and they were
counting the rounds to be more specific
seven and three on the side of
Chickering ranked u6 in four right now
so right now it definitely seems as JDC
r3o in this pool play and Chickering are
the top two placing right now to make it
out of this group or here we go JD CR
versus below alright so obviously pull
out here is just playing spoiler but you
know doesn't matter if you're playing
spoiler
personally I would say a ton of pride in
that listen I'm out but I need to make
your life worse right you're coming down
with me baby just imagine if we played
again that means I would've beat you
guys here lucky son of a gun so here I
believe let me let me let me do some
numbers here let me do some calculations
where's Obama with the TI 87 or whatever
I need I need I need graphs I think one
of the homies got went out in the crowd
oh crap I believe if G well if JD sir
wins this he will qualify in winners
guaranteed but I believe that if bulow
actually defeats him I would say I'm
really a JD cell we'll finish in second
place all right well here we go
JD see are solidifying his way into this
top eight and it looks like we sure
kicker is gonna make it no matter what
and this all happens so bolos biggest
fan right now has to be chickadee
because essentially he saves him a loss
mm-hmm put something puts them in the
winner's side guarantees him a top-five
finish yeah they're placing uh and
that's what you get here if we have not
said it before that top placing gives
you better seating spots in the top
eight it's a follow so these definitely
matter and that's why I say those
numbers do make sense
that round count victory up that three
oh that 3-1 is all pivotal when it comes
down to the final calculations to see
who's going to make that top eight but
here we go
Wow an interesting choice here I believe
frumble out not going with the Akuma not
going with the Bryant wait wait wait
let's let's let the people out there see
it let's let the people see it too but I
mean I'm very interested in this pick is
he locked in I don't even think he was
locked in yet not yet but you could tell
he's he's thinking about it he's
thinking about you and there you have it
let's see what stage we get we talked
about earlier yesterday when we felt
like there might not be one Mishima in
the finals wrong and wrong with him we
got one we got one come on
unlikely source yeah it might not be the
one we thought it was gonna be but devil
gene coming out from below hopefully
you're not you know I want to see him do
well here oh yeah most definitely
play it like you mean it play it like
you mean it manage a TCR today has
looked ready even though I think every
set every set he's won today has been to
one Oh small waver waver right there I
mean look we know that Palau is
definitely you know will burst in the
tournament scenario right yes maybe he
feels like this is one of the better
match I was right like there's no meter
characters on the screen this is
something that you fought with more and
then enough times right you know how to
fight this but you know so one thing
about Mishima is right you if you're not
on point with with the electrics and
with the health sweeps and whatnot it
could be you know if you're not mentally
prepared for it it could be tough to
just branch to just go you know go fine
the Shiva play right now yeah when
you're playing so many other characters
earlier I mean even more so that's the
difficulty of like Mishima's right old
hits the walls play yeah that's the
difficulty of Mishima's right like the
thing is is like they have high damage
they have the movement
but the execution is pivotal like if you
can't do that it's almost impossible to
be successful with a machine like this
black variation happens well I've never
seen the levels right yeah the songs hit
different but when you do commentary on
on these ones those astral headsets
broke broke and plate that's
disappointing a poor is such a little
kick right a broken foot I guess I just
do a few at the break plate it would be
like that I just didn't like the wanna
play that like I mean he just does that
move just to avoid the shards on the
floor watch a beat oh it was funny cuz
he's dead watch your feet oh down back
to wow challenge up Ginny's are you
gonna have to getting hit low nice duck
cliff allow it to Bob panting - gotta
get the wall as well
long gone too damaged wiping head back
the hands the axe and smash all blue
stuff hold that down too and that was
awful
quick three rounds from JD CR yes sir JD
sir looking good yeah I mean so many
people tried to avoid this boy
honestly I think it shows I mean Jimmy
sir this year hasn't really had like the
best year right no he's not
it feels like he's underperformed and
it's weird to say that when he's like in
top aides and you know winning a few
tournaments here and there but it really
does feel like he's underperforming
right when he's not dominating people
like he just did in this in this pool
stage it feels like and that's part of
like the transition right like a lot of
times what ends up happening is like
he's been searching for a new character
right like he talked about like how
playing armor King has heard him know
that he likes Hayati but then you have
to make the balance of like saying okay
well look I have a character already
that I'm good with but he's not working
out dragon elves always been there and
hey Ike you might not be the best choice
in this scenario yeah so now you have to
apply all of it you have to apply all of
that when you continue to stay on a
tournament circuit you get to the end
which is the technical world to it where
we are right now and of course it looks
a lot more sound right because he's
playing or more consistent with a more
consistent character and I mean if you
talk to a lot of people if you ask a lot
of people of etiquette
yeah and you know right now we see that
the players that have qualified for our
top eight these are players that have
been in the tournament team for quite
some time that used to this you know oh
yeah oh yeah and that's like in talking
about like below right they said he has
so much experience right which I
completely believe but this is a
different format than most right when
you get to like these specific game
tours they have a different format so
when you get to this part of it it gets
a little more difficult a little more
meticulous you got to be ready for
whatever they throw at you yeah and I
think we're gonna see below going back
to Brian his main you know interesting
enough the one thing
JDC right did saying that any of you was
I don't want to play against any 2d
characters I don't want playing against
meter characters right and balanc does
have an Akuma a very strong Akuma and
bang you know but I think he just might
not be
thinking about that he might not just be
confident right I mean if you think
about the fact like JD CR is definitely
one of those players who will wait for
you to kind of like hang yourself right
and I feel like he will definitely be
jabbing enough to make you respect it I
feel like he just knows how to play
around it he might not want to but I
know he knows how to play around it but
here we go Bulow going to the Brian but
you never know man you only get two
games and deciding to run you know in a
coma
just because he might not be ready you
know I might come back to bite you doing
yes sir I mean that's right that double
Jim pick might come back to haunt oh I
wonder what the idea was behind this
nice punch parry though things have been
super successful with also their orbital
as well that orbital has definitely
gotten some mileage while standing for
great pulps finishes the string as well
that JD looking very strong here right
now Wow just standing still giving
people that won't taste of their own
medicine look at the boots both standing
there keeping it in the middle of stage
on top of it like pretty close right now
allows back into the wall doc look at
the pit bulls are just like all right
don't touch the stick for like two
seconds man one two I have patients man
we talk about it all the time that's a
part of it the five step down four to 15
seconds left
man JD CR I don't know he must have
heat-seeking missile somewhere just like
that he knows where every wall is this
is goes off in his brain
yes chant itches he's like yo it's get
closer to the wall she's getting more
scratch yes a wall steady policy nice
big damage here all right like it he
just wanted to get him to that wall
watches two hits goes for okie nice and
we haven't seen him for many of those
outright yeah fight
while standing for working out a little
bit you see our watch what I was talking
about like he loves ABCs did you're
getting a little too anxious he'll put a
button out there but like what didn't do
it
JD starts just standing there not me
it's not something he would normally do
but I feels like he's just all right you
know you're gonna play like that I'll
play like that let's see how let's play
let's play some tech hands off the marae
bucko get off of me the patients were
both players here
Matt JD has been playing out of his mind
today as well I mean this is what you
want to do though right that patience is
really gonna help Wow don't watch the
blocks on it just so I can talk to oh my
god someone do something
again it's two rounds Fomalhaut Gopal
has some of the best rebuttal when it
comes to these the came by game scenario
that's the tournament expertise kicking
in like if you didn't see it with your
own eyes
you'll be see it right here like him
turning around these second matches he's
been consistent all day long nice got
the wall spot here from JD side wall
splats try to convert the combo oh no
great on the 1 plus to throw on the wall
and that's gonna be it the second game
goes to pull out me his second game
ratio is crazy yeah I mean it felt like
he kind of just hit the first one up -
just cuz picking the double gin right
and this is and this game right here is
huge for JD crg even even though he is
guaranteed to qualify for the top a this
match this game next will determine
whether or not he goes winners or losers
and of course you want to go on that
winter side you definitely want to make
a showing on that winter side going into
this top eight because uh you definitely
feel you've effectively made sure you're
playing the best players in the world at
this point a nice drop the couple fell
unfortunate drop the complet she was
off-axis Supermax finishes the string I
like the - of bobble out hit some away
from that corner get some successful low
bury eyes try to take this wall just off
access to so that there's a hit
and one of these compost beyond that on
axis or from or right just one time and
you can see both of them do these quick
side steps and that's why it keeps
happening
yep oh man the Mach capable of looking
good here oh yeah JT CRD about in a bit
of a pickle here
he was looking so good his first time in
this in this scent that allows Bentley o
counter-hit
oh no dropping so many crucial combos
down to once again quick trade hatchet
looking good for JD CR I didn't finish
it didn't think II was gonna be a
counter hit Wow what I'm calling it that
was sick
yeah it's beautiful ok ok JD CR ok ties
it up not one one folks your kid always
it's my favorite beret bro does it come
with
does it come with the ponytail I think
it's a tassel right is that actually a
ponytail his hair no way yeah you're
like a rookie not knowing that I'm
pretty sure those dragon offs bald on
top finally making the orbital count
he's definitely got in the wall and the
big need oh wait he's pull out on set
point versus Jamie CR this could put JDC
are in the losers side in the top eight
if he does not make something happen
do it again crabs in a barrel I'm
telling you you've written them all down
with you JD CR needs to tighten up right
now he's down around set point fumble
out trying to get away from that wall
almost had to split see a lot more
active in the movement for JD see y'all
get off of me and the side switch thing
more Mach breaker I stop their
philosophy Oh reverse oh that for two
takes it JD CR although he will advance
to our top eight it will be in the
looser side now chick wooden will be the
winners representative for pool see that
is crazy the fact that Chickering is
gonna go in on the winners side after
being down most of the group C plate but
Lao making a stamp this is what I'm
talking about out smile about that I'm
like hey good luck yeah I'll be in the
stands
sorry I had to put you there but you
know how it goes I think right at that
that up like yep I think that right see
you later
that can hold these results right here
you get seat group seat comes to a close
three one four Chickering three one four
also J DCR but that round this parent is
gonna make sure that he goes in on that
loser side chickering's gonna go in on
the winner site Ranchi to win to to go
home pull out two and two to go home as
well in st. not faring too well with the
oh and four but guys do me a huge favor
make some noise for rain chew but Lao as
well as st. those guys are gonna be
going home but they've had an amazing
taking world tour season and make sure
you go give those guys a follow show em
some love I'm gonna go do it in person
because that's just the kind of person
that I am
yes Man Group C I am good C comes to a
close but that's not the end of it
ladies and gentlemen we still have one
more group to go through before we can
close out this top eight Rickster it's
been a pleasure good sir always for your
family you know your family around these
parts but we're gonna take a quick break
but when we return when we return
Group D will give us the rest of our top
eight and it's gonna give us our finals
here at the Tekken world tour guys
please join us right after this break
can't wait
hey guys this avoid tasty Steve we're in
Bangkok Thailand you can see this
beautiful trophy beside me and this
beautiful representative of Bud Light I
mean we're here for Tekken 7 but one of
the things that helped Tekken 7 get
promoted ever so awesomely this year was
the Bud Light Tuesday Throwdown the bear
League helped us out tremendously
I mean it's very much it comes with the
ground in the fighting game community
that we evolved to start going online
and the fact that you guys have actually
helped us out and promoting the
ever-popular Tekken I really do
appreciate that how did you guys feel me
from your side I think that's cool right
yeah man I mean we're very excited it's
very very successful year one
partnership and we're very excited to be
here in Bangkok we actually brought the
winner of the beer league out here that
for the last-chance qualifier to compete
for the big prize pool I think what's
most important for us is the fans have
voted wouldn't saying that they really
like it they want more of this within
the fighting community and they want to
see more these online tournaments like
the beer league that we can actually
offer something back to the fans in
definitely offers to the fans you guys
have an amazing payout
you have a nice weekly structure on top
of that you guys include Tekken 7 now do
you guys think you would include other
games aside I mean the fighting game
community is a large place I mean we are
here for ticket but do you feel like
that's something that you guys will be
interested in because I guarantee you
the community will be ever so welcoming
if you guys want to come hang out with
us a little more on the online side yeh
yeah we would love to hear that from the
community first and foremost but we love
Tekken we'd love to bring back Tekken
but we're exploring other titles right
now like Soul Calibur for other 2020
partnerships and bring him back the beer
league in full force and even doubling
down and you guys even have a video game
show with a as well that we helped up
game over and we will we work with them
as well not all multiple items that
we've you had a chance to go on it so
how do you guys feel like that kind of
incorporates into your idea yeah no I
mean that's one plus one equals three so
game over is our show where we highlight
everything within the eSports community
but to be able to highlight the great
work that we've done together with the
Bud Light beer league it's just
incredible and then it's a totally
different fanbase that we're able to
share the fighting community and what
we're doing here together and it's
really been very valuable for us as a
brand as well as to the fans
well look I can tell you right now that
it's it means a lot to you and it means
a lot to like the fighting game
community I mean me personally but I
know the fighting game community
appreciates it and a lot of times I
don't get to play but I know rip is
played in it Rickster has played and if
some of my friends sook and a lot of my
friends have played it so I guarantee
you never think for a second or anybody
that watches the beer league or any
blood like thing where you guys help out
the FTC are video games in general that
we take it for granted cuz personally I
love what you guys are doing because it
makes it easy gets more eyes on both
parties and it helps everybody out
definitely for the fans just continue to
watch continue to drink some Bud Lights
and will continue to keep doing this and
coming back next year
well yo Joe I appreciate it it's been a
pleasure and we can have this
conversation again next year amen thank
you hey guys it's been a pleasure make
sure shoutouts the blood life for
helping out the fgc taken especially and
I'll see you guys next time peace